I want to please don't say anything
please just keep it to yourself whatever
Oh
thought you had an idea I do we need to
make an app like for a smartphone an app
that all the people could download and
then we make millions this is hard to
come up with medicine like catching
lightning in a bottle
I already got dad you got what lightning
in a bottle really what's the idea no no
idea
I got actual lightning in a bottle no
Levi that's just a phrase I got that dog
lightning in a bottle blip
that's crazy son but you get that some
old Chinese man sold it to me years ago
I mean that's some supernatural all it
does is this I got it my seriously man
would it be like an app that reminds you
when your favorite television shows are
wrong what bottle the bottle with the
lightning in it you still on that yes
how does it work surgery I don't know
it's the classic lightning in the bottle
get nothing you just
okay you know what you shouldn't have
this just belongs to the military or
something but that happened oh no we
don't need to app you've got the goose
that laid the golden egg how do you know
about honkers
what this mother August
giving on this app idea you like it yeah
he got a got-damn coordinator honkers
here is the cat's pajamas no please
don't throw I want to show you whatever
it is I don't want to see if it's
relevant I already know what it is
it ain't what you think well what I
think it is it's a pair of cat's pajamas
these are for honkers to wear go what
the Little Neck and man the neck how you
gonna fit his head do this thing with
the orange I have to ask you to leave my
house
why because you disrespected my roommate
okay okay it's clear that this is a
crazy house so I gotta go you over here
talking about geese or golden eggs and
feline sleepwear oh man Cedric you need
to get off your high horse man yeah I
just thought of a name for you
hi horse
[Music]
you